c'est l'un des pires cauchemars des
cyclistes une seconde d'inattention la
portière de l'automobile qui s'ouvre et
baigne on frappe un mur les
emporterrages en fait c'est la crainte
numéro un du cycliste
tout de suite
Véronique prince je disais avec nous
Michel David Geneviève Tellier bonsoir
et Sébastien Bavay que l'on retrouve
Sébastien bonsoir bonsoir Patrick depuis
le temps qu'on en parle à ce panel du
troisième lien c'est un peu comme notre
ami les gens ils disent ça se fera pas
ça va ça va notre panel politique tout
de suite
Véronique prince je disais avec nous
Michel David Geneviève Tellier bonsoir
et Sébastien Bavay que l'on retrouve
Sébastien bonsoir bonsoir Patrick depuis
le temps qu'on en parle à ce panel du
troisième lien c'est un peu comme notre
ami les gens ils disent ça se fera pas
ça va se faire il va une grosse annonce
jeudi Sébastien et on peut dire que ça
sera pas du tout le même projet voilà on
est en mesure de confirmer une nouvelle
d'abord publié par le Journal de Québec
selon laquelle le troisième lien entre
les vie et n'aura qu'un seul tunnel et
ce tunnel sera dédié aux transports en
commun alors le gouvernement abandonne
l'idée d'avoir un tunnel c'est-à-dire un
deuxième tunnel pour le transport
routier transport d'automobile c'était
un des arguments phares si on peut dire
du gouvernement le goût de dire il faut
désengorger en termes de véhicule
l'entrée de Québec avec les deux ponts
le pont de Québec et le pompier à la
porte d'où la nécessité d'avoir un
tunnel pour les autos entre Québec et
les vies mais là ils mettent de côté
cette idée là pourquoi parce que les
fameuses études dont on parle depuis des
mois en vienne à la conclusion qu'il y a
rien qui justifie d'avoir un tunnel pour
les autos entre Québec et les vies d'où
l'idée qui sera annoncée jeudi
officiellement d'avoir un seul tunnel
entre Québec et les vies pour le
transport en commun uniquement quel
transport en commun la question reste
ouverte on parce que j'ai posé la
question
le tramway peut-être bien j'ai posé la
question il y aura combien de voix dans
le tunnel pour le transport en commun on
m'a répondu je peux pas te le dire ça va
dépendre du mode de transport en commun
les sondages attendre que c'est
peut-être le tramway qui sera le mode de
transport en commun entre Québec et les
vis comme dit aussi de deux dernières
choses ce sera encore un projet de
centre-ville centre-ville donc centre
ville de Lévy vers le centre-ville de
Québec et à la question est-ce que le
prix sera révisé tu me dis attends jeudi
mais on me dit aussi si on construit un
tunnel au lieu de deux tunnels en
principe ça coûte moins cher et le prix
initial était 6 milliards et demi de
dollars et si on construit un tunnel qui
est destiné au transport en commun il y
a de l'argent qui arrive d'Ottawa voilà
du financement à la hauteur de 40% du
projet je pense c'est ça les critères du
gouvernement fédéral pour des projets de
transport en commun en effet ça fait
partie probablement de l'équation aussi
on ne s'ennuie jamais Sébastien merci
beaucoup très gentil d'être débarqué à
l'émission tour de table là-dessus c'est
le bon le grand recul stratégique que
l'on sentait se dessiner en tout cas que
beaucoup avaient prédit là je sais pas
si on sentait se dessiner Véronique qui
va s'effectuer jeudi
absolument en fait c'est une promesse
fort de la CAQ mais une promesse qui
faisait pas l'unanimité en fait parce
que ce soit au niveau du financement
qu'on réussit pas obtenir du
gouvernement fédéral aurait pas obtenir
l'appui du meilleur marchand ça faisait
l'objet des critiques des parties de
position on parlait aussi de la qualité
de l'air au centre-ville de quoi ça
aurait l'air avec ce projet-là puis le
coup qui était pharaonique de 6.5
milliards de dollars puis on l'avait
réduit alors la pandémie vient de donner
une fenêtre que le gouvernement devait
prendre si la prenait pas ben là ça
devenait trop tard pour reculer là il
peut utiliser l'excuse de la pandémie en
disant regardez là on a les données qui
démontrent qu'avec le télétravail
beaucoup moins de circulation donc notre
promesse elle est plus justifiée même si
on la trouvait très très bonne en 2018
qu'on vous l'a proposé le contexte a
changé donc il se devait de profiter de
cette fenêtre là s'il voulait reculer
sans que ça lui fasse trop mal
politiquement Michel David
qui avait dit à cette conférence de
presse là chez moi que les GES là puis
il y avait beaucoup de choses sur les
voitures dans la région ce sera pas ça
sera pas bien accueilli mais monsieur
Legault assez de capital politique de
points pour en perdre un peu là-dessus
oui je pense que si c'était entêté ça
aurait été encore pire parce que on sait
pas le jusqu'où ça aurait monté le déco
astronomique
je pense que comme disait Jean-Chrétien
il a quand tes peintures et dans le coin
le mieux c'est marcher ça la peinture
qui est à racler tes semelles un peu
après c'est certain que souvenez-vous
l'été dernier comme Monsieur Drainville
nous disait que c'était l'enfer sur les
pompes c'est épouvantables bon il y en a
qui vont être obligés de
ravaler un peu ce qu'ils ont dit mais au
total je pense que les gens dans
l'ensemble du Québec puis même à Québec
vous savez c'était pas si une anime que
ça il y a des gens sur la Rive-Sud oui
qui qui arrivaient mais sur la rive nord
c'est à moins évident alors si les coûts
sont moins si les
il résout aussi la contradiction entre
ces prétentions
environnementales et la construction
d'un tunnel qui aurait pratiquement été
l'équivalent de tous les jeux est-ce que
qu'on peut dégager dans une année alors
finalement je pensais la meilleure
solution y compris politiquement ouais
c'est une voix de sortie Geneviève
Tellier qui qui peut apaiser un peu tout
le débat pas même dans la perspective de
Monsieur le Gaulle peut-être un caillou
dans le soulier
oui puis moi je lis ça à ces fameuses
études qui ont on en parlait constamment
et c'était ça le problème de monsieur
Legault c'est qu'il y avait pas d'études
pour appuyer ces idées et j'ai
l'impression que il y avait beau refaire
les études probablement avec la pandémie
ça donnait ça aussi une fenêtre
d'opportunité mais les études le contrat
disait alors effectivement c'est sans
doute la solution qui va satisfaire la
majorité des gens et aussi ce qui se
passe avec monsieur Legault on le vit
avec la pandémie c'est que souvent
monsieur Legault a reculé à 10
publiquement effectivement ma première
idée c'est peut-être pas la meilleure je
vous ai écouté je suis prêt à faire
d'autres choses et ça ça le plus ça
fonctionne et donc on peut pas dire
qu'on est devant un gouvernement
dogmatique qui a une ligne de conduite
et qui veut pas interroger moi vous
savez j'ai un regard un peu sur
l'Ontario puis je vois ce que doc word
fait et lui il continue avec ses
autoroutes même si tout le monde dit ça
pas d'alerte il faut pas les construire
il va de l'avant alors je pense que pour
monsieur Legault puis au Québec ça va
être mieux accepter même s'il s'agit
d'une décision qui doit il doit changer
d'idées à propos d'une décision qui est
quand même importante c'est intéressant
Geneviève ce que vous soulignez parce
que très rapidement en conclusion
là-dessus Michel et Véronique c'est même
un trait de caractère que les Québécois
ont appris à aimer de plus en plus même
quand monsieur Legault disait on ferme
ceci non on le ferme plus et les gens
aimaient ça qui disent je me suis trompé
on recommence Michel oui au point
Patrice ou quand viennent décision qui a
l'air douteuse les gens commencent à se
dire mais c'est pas grave il va changer
d'idées il va falloir se rendre compte
que ça a pas de bon sens alors oui
monsieur LEGO a développé un personnage
là qui d'humilité si je peux dire qui
plaît
pas faut qu'il écoute aussi la
population s'il y a pratiquement sur peu
d'opposition là ça va être amusant
d'entendre quelques ministres quand même
là-dessus jeudi OK
Catherine Fournier je vous fais entendre
des réactions aujourd'hui des chefs de
parties qui ont tous salué le courage de
Madame Fournier
je trouve ça courageux la part de
Catherine d'avoir été jusqu'au bout du
processus et
je pense qu'un modèle je pense que c'est
un témoignage important et le vécu à
l'imparfait à travers le système ce
matin je vous saluer son courage je veux
saluer sa résilience aussi
elle prend la parole aujourd'hui
et je souhaite qu'on l'écoute si j'ai
une capture quelque chose à dire à la
victime aujourd'hui c'est dire au terme
de ce processus là qui sans aucun doute
a dû être douloureux difficile
j'espère que le fait que justice a été
rendu et que le système a fait son
travail lui donnera une paix intérieure
une voix je peux m'exprimer publiquement
je peux avoir une tribune donc si au
moins ça ça peut contribuer à mieux
protéger les victimes à l'avenir ou à
juste rendre la justice plus accessible
en participant à vulgariser le processus
judiciaire mais j'aurais fait un vrai
et c'est beaucoup revenu dans cette
longue conférence de presse à TVA parce
que un documentaire qui sera présenté
dans un réseau de Québécois sur toute sa
démarche ils l'ont suivi ce qui est
beaucoup revenu Véronique c'est que elle
a elle juge que le système la bien
accompagné que oui ça a été difficile à
prendre comme décision de porter plainte
ou pas il y a eu un combat intérieur
mais une fois la question prise elle
était bien accompagnée et ça c'est un
message d'espoir effectivement et je
comprends que c'est son objectif
justement de dévoiler son identité parce
que c'est jamais agréable de devoir le
faire publiquement comme ça c'est quand
même très privé lorsqu'il s'est passé
dans sa vie par contre moi ce qui m'a
marqué c'est que lorsque un journaliste
lui a demandé à ce que vous avez senti
le même accompagnement même soutien des
élus elle a répondu à un nom sec j'ai
pas de difficulté à le croire parce que
moi je me rappelle quand c'est arrivé
cette histoire-là premièrement tout le
monde ici on était sous le choc il y
avait beaucoup de députés tout partis
confondus qui était autant sous le choc
parce que Harold Lebel
le capital de sympathie important
c'était quelqu'un qui était pas partisan
qui était pas réputé pour être agressif
au contraire qui était collaboratif en
général tout le monde les met au
Parlement chez les députés ici et donc
elle a probablement dû se battre un peu
contre ce préjugé favorable qu'avait
Harold Lebel puis à ce moment-là quand
je dis ça on savait pas là que sa
victime était Catherine Fournier l'homme
mais étant donné que lui avait un gros
capital de sympathie probablement
qu'elle a du BAT comme ça aussi ici au
Parlement Michel David vous retenez quoi
de cette sortie
où elle raconte abondamment tout le
processus et c'est assez éclairant pour
quelqu'un qui n'a pas connu ça ou
quelqu'un qui aurait peut-être envie qui
a été victime d'aller vers le système de
justice c'était clair madame Fournier
nous dit que elle a été comment dire
bien prise en charge dans le processus
si je faisais et que ça a très bien été
mais elle raconte aussi combien malgré
tout ça ça a été difficile qu'à chaque
étape quand il y a eu des repas ou qu'à
un moment donné il a fallu décider entre
un jury ou un juge qu'à toutes les fois
à se poser des questions et moi je la
connais un peu pour savoir que c'est une
femme qui est capable de prendre des
décisions plus que que le commun des
mortels je faisais alors je peux
imaginer que pour quelqu'un qui a pas
que plus froid aux yeux qu'elle disons
ça demeure un processus extrêmement
difficile et juste pour compléter ce que
Véronique disait à propos de du milieu
politique et de la réaction qui a eu je
pense moi aussi que assez fait un peu
largué par par la classe politique mais
il faut dire qu'à ce moment-là aussi
entre l'événement et l'accusation à
l'état devenu une orpheline politique
elle avait démissionné du PQ alors là
elle avait pas de d'amis autour d'elle
d'amis politiques je devrais dire
c'était pas les parties de position qui
déjà la même moins parce que tu es au PQ
puis là les pékistes l'aimaient plus
parce que tu es parti alors ça doit être
très difficile
au PQ mais j'ai pas le contact après là
Geneviève vous impressions sur cette
journée portes
son courage et je pense que son
témoignage va avoir beaucoup d'impacts
qui étaient importants mais ce que
j'aimerais aussi saluer c'est la
personnalité politique souvent on a
l'impression que les politiciens
agissent en politique c'est-à-dire que
je vais faire telle intervention je vais
essayer de marquer des points marqués
des coups dans ma carrière politique et
on voit que c'est pas le cas avec
Catherine Fournier c'est une personne
qui prend en fait un risque politique
énorme parce que très rapidement des
gens pourraient facilement lui donner
lui a posé l'étiquette victime mais ça
reste collé à sa peau pour le reste de
sa carrière et donc cette prise de
risque-là doit aussi être saluée parce
que en tant que politicienne en tant que
personnalité publique elle s'expose elle
parle de sa vie privée ce n'est pas
facile et elle le fait pour faire un
bruit de comme elle le dit pour rendre
service à la société et je pense que ça
aussi ça doit être salué on l'oublie
fréquemment que pour les politiciens de
toujours être sous le feu de la rampe
devant les caméras
à toutes sortes de critiques certaines
qu'on voit venir d'autres qu'on voit pas
venir et c'est très courageux de sa part
je vous dirais de vouloir témoigner de
ce qui s'est passé parce que elle aurait
pu tout simplement choisi de dire j'ai
fait ce qu'il fallait faire
le processus judiciaire a suivi son
cours ça sert à bien fonctionné dans mon
cas et j'ai je m'arrête là parce que
elle a été un petit peu plus sûr pour
elle mais elle a choisi la voie de la
difficulté c'est tout à son honneur une
transparence qui était pas calculée une
transparence qui peut être salutaire
puis pour la suite des choses mais elle
ne veut pas être définie comme vous avez
bien dit comme une victime est poursuit
mais reste de Longueuil ok on vous a vu
dans ce reportage là Geneviève Tellier
commenté le prochain sujet on change de
sujet totalement je veux entendre pierre
poirievre qui interroge monsieur Trudeau
à la période des questions Ottawa sur ce
voyage qu'il a fait en Jamaïque chez les
Green une famille riche d'origine
britannique mais qui habite
à plusieurs endroits sur la planète où
Monsieur Trudeau est allé passer ses
vacances de Noël on écoute on revient
on apprend aujourd'hui qu'il a non
seulement forcé ses mêmes contribuables
à payer 160 000 dollars pour ces
vacances mais qu'il a reçu une vacance à
une villa luxueux d'une donateur de la
Fondation trou d'eau est-ce que le
premier à payer pour ses propres
hébergements à ces villages on a
toujours travaillé avec le commissaire
haltique pour s'assurer que toutes les
règles soient fuites suivies mais si le
chef de l'opposition était réellement
préoccupé par le coût de la vie pour les
Canadiens il sera en train d'appuyer
notre budget
mais le Premier ministre un obstant les
autorisations du commissaire à l'éthique
aurait dû
écouter un petit ange sur son épaule qui
aurait dû lui dire tu t'en vas te rouler
dans l'opulence de tes amitiés
familiales pendant que il y a 60% des
cotisants à l'assurance emploi qui n'y
aurait pas droit s'ils en avaient besoin
il y a quelque chose là-dedans qui
dépasse un peu l'entendement et qui nous
amène au manque de jugement
bon Geneviève Tellier est-ce que il y a
un manque de jugement évident d'après
vous parce que le commissaire l'éthique
a dit vous pouvez y aller ce sont des
vrais amis c'est pas comme si c'était
des gens qui voulaient influencer a dit
le commissaire à l'éthique qu'en
pensez-vous
oui il y a eu des manques de jugement
plusieurs niveaux mais celui qui pour
moi le plus important c'est que c'est un
voyage exorbitant je veux dire vous et
moi qui est en contente parce qu'on
pense aller en voyage puis qu'on voit
qu'on a pas les moyens de se le payer on
y va pas et je pense que il devrait y
avoir un réflexe au gouvernement je
pense ajuster Trudeau mais pas juste son
entourage aussi ou un moment donné on
devrait se dire à 160 000 dollars pour
un voyage d'une semaine dans le sud
c'est trop cher peu importe si c'est des
amis peu importe si c'est parce qu'on
est le premier BD ça coûte plus cher
c'est faux assurer la sécurité mais il y
a un montant qui me semble
pour lequel il faut pas faut pas payer
puis 160000 il me semble énorme juste
pour vous faire une comparaison le
salaire annuel de Justin Trudeau est à
peu près 400 000 par année alors ce
voyage là a coûté la moitié de son
salaire annuel c'est comme si vous et
moi avons des faits que la moitié de mon
salaire je le prendrai pour une semaine
de vacances et j'aimerais que dans
l'entourage on réfléchisse aussi à ça
qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour contrôler des
qui me semble atteint des proportions
énormes je vais faire un tour de table
et je vais revenir Geneviève après je
vais vous poser la question est-ce qu'un
premier ministre donc à vos yeux peut
aller en vacances ou pas parce que toute
la sécurité vient avec ça coûte cher
mais Michel votre vos impressions ben
moi je pense que son entourage a bien
essayé de lui expliquer que ça va pas de
bon sens et je pense que Monsieur
Trudeau c'est très bien que ça a pas de
bon sens mais il s'en sac il y a décidé
je le fais pareil il me fait un peu
penser à Monsieur fusil Gabin des fois
qui qui fait des choses tout le monde
n'ont pas de bon sens et qui se dit moi
je le fais pareil alors Monsieur Trudeau
il s'assume je pense que il va vite il
est prêt à vivre avec quoi développer
pourquoi ça a pas de bon ça ça a pas de
bon sens parce que Monsieur Trudeau
mène un train de vie qui est sans
commune mesure avec les Canadiens qu'il
prétendent défendre il y ait déjà ils
prennent déjà flans des accusations de
la part des conservateurs d'avoir nourri
l'inflation d'être un peu responsable de
la hausse du coût de la vie qui fait en
sorte les gens de la misère à joindre
les deux bouts puis faut savoir comme ça
ça pavanner avec des milliardaires dans
des paradis
extraordinaires
les gens vont être choqués et ce que je
veux dire c'est que c'est député eux qui
vont payer aussi le prix politique non
pas eux au moins la compensation d'avoir
passé des vacances extraordinaires alors
aux autres c'est pertes
Véronique bon c'est sûr que Monsieur
Trudeau peut avoir des arguments que
c'était ses amis effectivement qu'une
famille ça fait plusieurs années que
tout pouvoir quel droit de voyager etc
mais ça devient une question de
perception ça devient une question
d'image alors il est là en fait le
problème parce que le commissaire
alexique a donné son feu vert mais même
si le commissaire allait-il dit oui le
problème de Monsieur Trudeau en ce
moment c'est que ça s'ajoute à une liste
et peut-être que s'il était en début de
mandat ce serait un autre histoire les
gens seraient prêts à passer par de ça
mais là vous l'ajoutez à toutes les cont
finalement des dernières semaines les
gens peuvent avoir une confusion aussi
avec l'autre voyage qu'il avait fait à
l'île de la gacane qui dans ce cas là la
le commissaire avait blâmé parce qu'on
disait mais dans ce cas-là c'est pas un
ami alors que là il peut dire oui mais
cette fois-ci ce sont mes amis ce sont
des proches de la famille donc il peut y
avoir une espèce de confusion qui fait
que la perception et l'image est pas
bonne pour lui donc vous dites les et
vous êtes d'accord les trois que parce
que Monsieur Trudeau et a de l'argent
puis quand il quittera la politique il
va avoir de l'argent vous êtes il fera
ça quand il sera plus Premier ministre
il ira voir ses amis milliardaires parce
qu'il a le droit d'avoir des amis
milliardaires c'est un fait c'est des
amis de 50 ans de la famille ont aussi
ça là ces documenté mais vous dites
Geneviève Michel et Véronique tant qu'on
conserve l'État et le public on a un
poste élu on ne peut pas se permettre ce
genre de vacances vous allez jusque là
j'aime bien
ah oui puis je pense que Michel très
vieille résumé le fond de la pensée oui
attendra quand il y aura terminé son
mandat s'ils veulent encore l'inviter la
famille grüne à aller passer une semaine
en Jamaïque ben il ira puis aucun
problème mais je continue à dire c'est
un coup trop élevé où Olivier qui ont
trop élevé qui nous laisse
aller dans le même monsieur Lévesque
allait dans le même il y avait pas
autant de sécurité ou monsieur Paris si
elle est ailleurs ou il y a des coûts
qui incombent à la sécurité monsieur
Legault a été très bronzé que j'allais
dans le sud il va pas le seul Geneviève
vous serons c'est ça
et je m'attends pas à ce qu'il paye tout
inclus à 2000 dollars pour une semaine
il va payer plus que ça par contre je
vais vous rappeler le corps et ça en
Angleterre quand il est allé au
funérailles de la reine où il y a pris
une chambre à 6000 dollars la nuit je
veux dire il y a des chambres à
l'ambassade canadienne à Londres on peut
aller là puis ça coûte rien donc je
trouve qu'il y a pas ce souci là
Monsieur Trudeau devrait demander à son
de bien faire le travail son entourage
devrait arrêter de penser qu'il y a pas
de limite à ce qu'on doit dépenser pour
la sécurité du Premier ministre donc en
quelques secondes Véronique et Michel
d'écouter l'emploi j'en peux plus vous
dites Michel oui d'abord je suis
convaincu que son entourage là c'est
desespéré le devoirs qui sont pas
capable de contrôler monsieur le goût à
Monsieur monsieur Legault monsieur
Trudeau monsieur
Trudeau plus que ça et Monsieur Trudeau
il peut prendre des vacances il y a
besoin de vacances très certainement et
même s'il prend ses vacances au Canada
il va avoir besoin de sécurité puis on
va lui en donner mais il y a des limites
là
ce vautrer dans le luxe alors que il
arrête pas de dire que les Canadiens
doivent faire des sacrifices puis c'est
pas facile de pas être hébergé par des
multimilliardaires nécessairement
Véronique conclusion
en fait quand on est rendu dans un
deuxième troisième mandat il faut être
encore plus prudent parce qu'on est
encore plus scruté à la loutre et c'est
ce que ça démontre et que c'est des
images qui restent on voit déjà le
sketch du Bye Bye on voit c'est des
images qui restent en fait c'est ça
qu'il faut être conscient de ça à vous
trois merci beaucoup pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]